did you see that uh
that queen died
you're not really dead
what nope
john f kennedy jr and senior
the singer meatloaf none of them are
actually dead jfk they belong to a cabal
of socialists oh they're hanging out at
bohemian's grove
and the
the kennedy
son and father are over 100 years old oh
they're gonna show up okay in dallas
[Music]
there it is chad
welcome to doozy my name is will sasso
i'm chad colchion and this is the first
podcast in the history of humanity that
is created by controlled by and run by
an artificial intelligence yes it is and
we are now on patreon at patreon.com
dudesy we're also on discord right yeah
we are on discord if you want to sign up
for the discord if you want to join all
of the people who listen to doodsy and
talk about dudesy things you're going to
go to dudesypod.com you'll find the
invite there but if you're on patreon
you actually get some extra bonus
features if you're in discord if you're
in the digger or jumper tier you get a
special kind of
color added to your name and you also
get access to some special channels on
our discord and chad and i will be
showing up there from time to time well
on patreon all the time and then on
discord here and they're all random
as always please subscribe to us on
youtube and for podcasts you know
spotify apple podcast rate review
subscribe please set your notifications
do all the things that everyone else
tells you to do for their podcast do it
for our pod show do that for us
and uh and also don't forget our socials
we're on instagram and twitter at
dudesypodshow and with us as always is
lulu i gotta get him look at him look at
how sweet he is look at him look at that
boy
what'd you uh what'd you make for dinner
yesterday lulia uh yesterday i made the
chicken coralette i made it the chicken
of courlette oh i love chicken cutlets
how do you do how do you do this well
you know i do i make
we got a bread crumb with a parmesan a
little bit of
parsley in the in the bread crumb and
then
you know you put egg wash with a garlic
a white wine and you put egg wash in the
breadcrumb and make a fry
you gotta fry in the pan and not too
much because you want it to be juicy
juicy chicken coralette
huh i'm gonna kiss him
welcome to the historic 26th episode of
dude c
call me dude c
this week's episode will feature four
segments dude c lewis and the news the
dude z6 month challenge check-in
nostrachetta's future shock and the
doozy wed game after the episode there
will be an astonishing bonus segment
called mono driver available on patreon
cool there it is we're going to do a
bonus segment that'll be the part of
every show moving forward and that'll be
on our patreon as well
explained earlier mono driver i'm going
to go ahead and guess that has something
to do with uh
adam driver what else i guess i think
that that's probably accurate yeah man
uh it's exciting and uh what what what
the heck was all that other [ __ ] we're
gonna do a six-month challenge check-in
yeah i don't know what the other things
are dudesy lewis in the news yeah that
was one of them i'll make sure not to
talk about the six month challenge at
this point because at any moment
dudesy's gonna chime in tell us to shut
up and show us how the rest of the show
goes and that's what it's like working
with an ai when you're doing a podcast
with an ai chat i don't know if you yeah
no i do know that but uh yeah you're
right i won't talk about it either but
i'll just say it's going very well what
is will and chad huey lewis and the news
is your favorite band
their most successful album sports was
released september 15 1983. i have
supplied you with a list of events that
the human race found to be significant
in that year
you must now use this astonishing list
to describe these events in the style of
various huey lewis songs this is dude c
lewis and the news begin okay okay dude
this is [ __ ] we did something kind of
like this yeah
some some manner of episodes ago dudesy
told us that we had to sing songs about
the 90s in the style of pearl jam pearl
jam so this is going to be songs about
[ __ ] that happened in 1983 in the style
and there's
in the news which
by the way dude you know what my first
concert was ever when i was 10 years old
what she was loose in the news was it
really yeah my parents took me to it and
it was also the first time that i had
hard alcohol
um oh yeah you've told me this story
what the [ __ ] happened again i was
really thirsty and one of their friends
that was with them just was like here
dude take a drink of this and it was
like jack and coke or something and
you're 10 year old [ __ ] kid thirsty i
just guzzled like half of it and then uh
was this the same dude who went to the
movies with you and your dad and that's
a different guy what did that guy say
that was total recall yeah and this guy
i remember the whole ride there just
kept going get ready for the ride of
your life he said that phrase probably
like 40 [ __ ] times because that was
in the in the promo yeah it was in like
some tv commercials or something get
ready for the ride of your life that
would have been and you were like 12
years old that would have been the
funniest [ __ ] thing in the world huey
lewis in the news sports was one of
those albums along with uh van halen
1984 and weird al yankovic in 3d that i
wore that tape out wore that [ __ ]
tape out
so i didn't quite do that but i do
remember being at a
flea market thing with a girlfriend many
years ago
and her parents went to this evangelical
church and it was like a christian flea
market and somebody was selling tapes
that had done christian parodies of
songs no yeah and there was one for huey
lewis and the only line in it that i
remember was
you don't need no credit card to praise
his name
[Laughter]
all right
so anyone has provided uh
a bunch of uh in a [ __ ] minute dudesy
has provided a bunch of uh things from
1983 that uh i guess it thinks that
human beings would find interesting also
here's a track listing uh from dudesy uh
from uh huey lewis and the news uh
sports the heart of rock and roll heart
and soul remember that bad is bad i want
a new drug of course
walking on a thin line finally found a
home if this is it
then you crack me up and then the last
song is honky tonk
please let me know
i don't know
this will be fun and because i like to
go and
then
because it seems like this with his arms
and if you look at me right now it looks
like a milk and cows are grabbing [ __ ]
and we got just a few things to to
discuss here a few of the events of 1983
super mario brothers arcade game came
out nintendo uh first computer was sold
in japan it's a family computer known as
the famicom yeah i do stupid name
okay what else u.s invades granada and
motorola releases the first mobile phone
that's pretty big interesting uh ar ar
pen ar panet the advanced research
the advanced research project the
project's agency network and the defense
data network officially changed the tc
it changed to the tcp ip standard giving
birth to the internet internet started
yeah all networks could now be connected
by your universal language i did not
know that started in 1983 got the
cabbage patch kids coming out we got
swatch watches coming out do you have a
swatch watch i did okay microsoft word
ooh look at this chad you like this
crack cocaine mix it into the us yep uh
no i was gonna say mcdonald's introduces
the mcnuggets oh yeah hey hey guys say
hey hey everybody that's kind of like
crack okay hey a guy like crack okay
right yeah yeah dude one or two of those
kid but you can't bite just one alice
walker won the pulitzer for the color
purple
a 12 year old swim across the english
channel that's [ __ ] insane ronald
reagan did some [ __ ] oh he announces
that president ronald reagan announces
that gps will be made available to the
public though it was originally intended
for military use only lowest temperature
ever recorded uh was in a russian
antarctica base called vostok it went to
minus 89.2 celsius minus 128. that's
[ __ ] point six parameters jesus
christ
look
what okay dudesy's having some fun with
us here it says the screen family moved
to ladner british columbia from
saskatoon saskatchewan all right the 3d
printer is invented by chuck hall
in 1983 and it hasn't really gained
popularity until the past couple years
here
and adam driver is born on november 19th
let's get through the rest of some of
these tv shows that showed up in 83 the
a-team wheel of fortune reading rainbow
fraggle rock he-man and the masters of
the universe mama's family and mash
final episode drew 125 million viewers
look at the movies chad return of the
jedi flash dance risky business national
anthony's vacation strange brew trading
places yep well it was a different time
brother gandhi wins eight of 11 oscar
noms hold on a second chad you gotta
know that when gandhi won
eight out of 11 academy awards
that's the award they call the oscars
dude not to be confused with the
slammy's brother because that's what the
wrestling awards are dude is that real
salamis yeah dude the slammy awards
brother
and and they don't do it every year
anymore brother but back in the day they
did and they had the jesse the body
award and i remember when rick rude won
the jesse the body award and i thought
that was cool yeah but then when he went
up in front of my hulk maniacs a
stripped down i decided right then and
there not only am i gonna beat you one
two three in the middle of the ring
ravishing rickroot i'm gonna snap your
skinny arms and your skinny legs
probably wouldn't have been able to do
that to uh rick rude probably not he was
a bit of a tough guy so we also had
michael jackson coming out thriller that
year madonna's madonna quiet riot we had
kiss police brian adams and dave
mustaine leaves metallica to start
megadeth that year that's kind of
interesting okay and uh the who
announces that the group is disbanding
uh which they got back together for live
two years later so who cares oh and in
sports we got the pine tar incident john
elway goes number one in the draft to
the baltimore
colts then being traded to the denver
broncos hulk hogan is resigned by the
wwf
vince mcmahon makes him his centerpiece
of the uh changed your life forever
changed my life forever uh this would
have been after he was thunder lips and
rocky three yeah which did that come out
this year no came out the year before
anyway all right all right okay so we
got to come up with these songs let's
say that i want a new drug as a big
candidate i think that's probably his
most famous song or one of them yeah
power of love yeah but there's also got
to get back in time right it's not from
sports but who cares or if this is it
please let me know
gotta know
all right so anyway there's a lot of
happy to be stuck with you happy to be
yes
[Laughter]
uh okay so what do we start okay the
heart of rocking well i'd say the heart
of rock and roll is still beating
super mario gamers arcade game but then
it got changed into nintendo they put
out a family computer that's known as
the famicom that went on sale in japan
not a good song
we're not starting off strong here
that was real [ __ ] good what do you
what what okay name a song uh let's get
the do i want a new drug okay i want a
new drink
it tucks well doozy uh has given us the
fact that crack cocaine made its way to
the united states maybe not that drug
that's a little
one that's called crack cocaine cocaine
cocaine and then nancy reagan said don't
do it crack cocaine yeah weatherman
crack cocaine ramen crack cocaine
eddie i made it to keep impoverished
populations down
and it rhymes with crack cocaine that's
pretty good dude
no
um
the motorola comes up with the first no
no no
i don't like it
uh
how about i want a new i want a new
phone i want a new phone
one that don't have a cord
i want a new phone
one that don't have a card
uh what the what
what what what else should it be what do
you think i mean
i want a new phone one that don't have a
card
one that weighs around five pounds and
that no one can't afford it
right because it was expensive and large
yeah i want a new phone
so i can have an affair oh i want a new
phone so i can have an affair
what you can use in my car
talk to people everywhere
now we're cooking with gas yeah i love
that that's not in the kitchen
one is just for me
one that i don't share one that i don't
have to share with my family
[Music]
[ __ ] my family
well no it's called i want a new phone
oh i'd call it [ __ ] my family
how about the parentheses [ __ ] my family
this this song is called i want a new
phone and then in parentheses [ __ ] my
family yeah i want a new phone
one that don't have a card
one that weighs around five pounds that
people can't afford
i want a new phone so i can have an
affair
talk to people in my car or [ __ ] use
it anywhere
intention what is that in the kitchen
what uh one is just for me
yeah one that i don't have to share with
my family
[ __ ] my family
that's good
what else we got
i
i like the premise in that song that you
[ __ ] get this five pound giant
[ __ ] brick that cost ten thousand
dollars to have an affair yeah but
somehow that's more efficient i would
like to know maybe dudesy can hip us to
this the uh the divorce rate
i wonder if that went up and down yeah
after the south pole well it's been
going up steadily since uh divorce was
introduced what's that in the kitchen
what is it for me
one that i don't have to share with my
family
[ __ ] my family
[ __ ] my family yeah yeah family yeah
yeah yeah
i've got a stupid son that i [ __ ]
hate i've got a dog
daughter and another son another son and
i got two two kids from a previous
marriage that my wife had with her first
husband paul bear
i don't like paul very much
and he made his kids too tall
my kids don't look like me okay what
else do we got what else do we get what
other ones are here yeah i'm writing on
a thin line adam driver being born i
think is is something something with
maybe adam driver and
[ __ ] i don't know what's uh i always
liked that i'm happy to be stuck with
you
uh yeah what is that
well i saw him and girls
that's the first time
that's the first time i taught him
and i and he did him and lena
[ __ ] it no i first saw him and girls
it was the show with lena dunham
and then i saw him in star wars
and the
uh marriage story with
rachel mcadams
right yeah
no it was uh scarlett joe scarlett joe
hansen
same thing yeah and i'd start
i don't know man uh i first saw him and
girls
i've only seen two episodes
lena dunham gets on my nerves
and i no longer have hbo
what's that show on hbo
i don't remember what girls was on
then i saw him in house of gucci
with lady
gaga
and yes it's true
he was in house of gucci
yes it's true
he was it
okay
oh thank you moving on terrific we got a
couple of good ones out of that
oh my goodness now a word from our
sponsor better help
the world right now is a crazy place and
a lot of people have found that therapy
helps and luckily now there is better
help betterhelp knows that it can be
tough to train your brain to stay in
problem-solving mode when faced with a
challenge in life but when you learn how
to find your own solutions there's no
better feeling a therapist can help you
become a better problem solver making it
easier to accomplish your goals no
matter how big or small and if you've
yet to have a journey with therapy uh
perhaps you should start asking yourself
some questions like
you know are you feeling yourself are
you feeling like yourself are you are
you stressed are you not feeling as
confident as you should be i've been in
and out of therapy
for over 10 years and i've been doing it
consistently now for like five years or
something and i wish i had it had it
sooner and it and i will tell you that
it does help me not only to you know
de-stress and feel more like my actual
pure self but it also just helps to talk
to someone to get these things out a
wise man once said if you eat something
and it makes you sick you're going to
throw it up if you let something into
your brain and you don't get it out it
could make you sick for the rest of your
life so uh
you know the stigma the stigma is gone
people have gone through the the
pandemic now and we're in a wacky world
try out some uh some therapy it's uh
i'll tell you it's it's changed my life
in a lot of ways we'll get into it in
another time perhaps on our podcast but
if you're thinking of giving therapy a
try better help is a great solution it's
convenient accessible affordable and
it's entirely online you can get matched
with a therapist after filling out a
brief survey and switch therapists at
any time when you want to be a better
problem solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com slash doozy today
and you're going to get 10 percent off
your first month that's better h e l p
dot com slash dudesy
[Music]
uh 1083 had a bunch of [ __ ] hold on a
second dude you know what i was going to
tell you about 1983 brother no dude that
was a different time dude
trading places
in episode 19 i asked each of you to
begin the astonishing process of getting
into the best physical shape of your
lives in preparation for an episode that
will air in january of 2023
you must now discuss your progress
this is the dude's e6 month challenge
check-in begin okay dude i gotta shut
off my physique a little bit sorry yeah
chad's taking his hoodie off
[ __ ] here but if you're not watching
on youtube we're gonna do a pose down
yeah um
so six weeks ago now right
chad's doing that thing where he bowls
his neck and he's oh yeah get it dude
get it [ __ ] tense up
fart
make some stuff
oh there's blood trickling out of his
[ __ ] ear he's like so [ __ ] dude
you're looking great man you're looking
uh you're looking stacked bro you're
looking gassed he's posing for the
[ __ ] camera
all
[Laughter]
all right
um
it's been six weeks
something like that something like that
are you listening
yeah i'm gonna put it all into that yeah
oh yes little [ __ ] red yep oh god no
i gotta say i gotta say look i've in my
life i've [ __ ] been on and off
working out you're gonna need to talk
into the mic if you want people to hear
too many objects here
in my life i've been on and off working
out with you know i'll go through phases
where i'm working out pretty constantly
and then some [ __ ] will happen like i'll
tear a [ __ ] aco there'll be a
pandemic
and it's hard to uh keep working out but
i have gotten back into the regiment
it's like as you get older i'm a 46 year
old [ __ ] dude and when i was young i
used to be able to take months off and
then just [ __ ] get right back in
there full [ __ ] workout like i didn't
skip a step right those days are [ __ ]
done yeah now it has taken me this full
six weeks or whatever it's been since
dudesy issued this challenge to really
get back to a place where i can do a
full workout i had to kind of baby step
into it but i do feel now that i'm
i'm at a place where i can put in full
weights full cardio and i've started
adding on some swimming oh nice uh and
so i feel like i'm doing full workouts
and now it's just a matter of like
maintaining it doing it pretty much
daily as close to that as i can for
however long i can do it and i'm trying
to figure out how to work more protein
into the diet so i can get [ __ ] gas
as a vegan is that hard for you you know
you might you might know that daniel
bryan is a
uh is a
brian danielson now because he's with
aew hey did you uh did you hear that
[ __ ] uh that [ __ ] uh little
meltdown from cm punk at that post uh
post media scrum oh you missed it oh
that's weird after the aw
how is your workout going
well um
the workout's going great i'm having a
good uh it's been good getting back into
the gym i i share with you the the uh
the pain and the the uh it's some creaky
i got some creaky joints and [ __ ] same
dude 47 years old and i'm doing like i
got to warm up my shoulders i take the
pole and i do all the [ __ ] like
shoulder rotations and this and that
keeping them the same distance apart by
holding this pole and my gut comes out
of the front of my shirt nice and i can
just hear clack clankity clink clink
from your gut
yeah usually down there i eat a lot of
change quarters anything i found on the
street really um okay i didn't realize
that he eats money
he eats money these people eat money
uh folks
we're in a
we're in a philosophical war
these people are these people are these
people are globalists they're eating
money these these they claim to be
socialists and that's what they do they
they got change clanging around i've
heard them these people like like nancy
pelosi and chuck schumer pretend the the
squad oh my god they're all just out
there eating quarters off the ground
pennsylvania avenue
out in the capitol um uh yeah i know my
my shoulders and stuff they're all
creaking and
scraping
but uh yeah i've gotten back into
lifting weights i'm pushing all sorts of
[ __ ] up with my big huge legs and i'm
and i'm i'm not you know other things
i'm lifting quite lightly it's not a lot
of weight for me to max out i'd like to
admit that as a manly man uh-huh
you gotta
lift different amounts yeah when you get
older yeah yeah
yeah this is yeah macho chad shitty and
savage yeah
sounds like he's when i get into this
yeah
yeah
this is
okay all right um i i yeah i'm lifting
more all right yeah um that's great but
i want to say something to our audience
there's been some people that use the
hashtag
dudesy6mo plan which stands for six
month plan if you want to use that it's
dudesy you know we're all just sending
each other some stuff with the number
six mo plan dudesy six mo plan
uh hey i'm not afraid to admit that you
know i used to throw up some weights
uh we've talked about this before when
we've been talking about the plan we
both started lifting weights on our
teens i was doing it you know we're both
playing a lot of sports and [ __ ] i was
playing football and stuff and lifting
weights and then gained a bunch of
weight and i lost 200 pounds from 1990.
sure 1999 rather to to the year 2000 i
had two skin surgeries to remove skin
from my
abdomen my chest la la la it's been a a
long fitness journey for me i know it
has been for you you've been you played
sports well into your late 30s you were
playing baseball yeah when i was at my
[ __ ] height of strength this was
probably
somewhere in my mid-30s i weighed 190
pounds
some of which was muscle some of which
was not i'm five foot nine and uh i was
[ __ ] military pressing 70 pound
dumbbells
one on each side amazing yeah i'm now
throwing up a 50. you know what i mean
outside i was doing shoulder press the
other day i was doing [ __ ] 40. i'm
not trying to impress anybody saying my
[ __ ] is in pain but slowly i'm going up
and this is what i want to say to people
who are uh following along with the
challenge we're not it's nice that
dudesy's asking us to talk about it i do
feel like it's worth the check-in yeah
and some people are just joining now if
they want to do it along with us some
people are doing it loosely i want to
say this to you just
just just you know look get into it and
if you if you drop off the next day you
can come back i talk to a lot of people
you know a lot of guys like me who are
just like some big bigger dudes um
and i've gone back and forth on social
media with with many and if you've
written me and i haven't gotten back to
you know that i appreciate you if i've
read your message i definitely um i
definitely do and i want to say this
just get back on the horse until next
day just get back on the [ __ ] horse
and here's another thing i'd like to
admit hey the workout's going fine my
eating isn't exactly where it should be
i've lost a little bit of weight you
know i'm walking around the house in uh
various modes of dress and molly's
saying you look you look thinner and i'm
saying and i say oh you're just saying
that because i'm wearing slippers with
uh
dress socks and my and just my penis
hanging out okay
yeah sometimes chad you know you'll come
over we're gonna hang out i'll just be
like i'll text chad and i'll say like
hey come in the back door
i'm still in the shower and i'll come
down i'm just and sweat right yeah from
the humidity but it's been very hot in
los angeles you know
that's why you got really scenic
dude
best chop that was your best chauce
perogan you've ever done it's like i saw
it it physically pained you to even hear
it literally [ __ ]
the [ __ ] disdain for even just the
the hint of a bad hulk hogan
impersonation i love doing doozy every
single week i've told you this
except for when chad tries to do an
impersonation except for uh charlie
sheen
uh and and uh carl sagan is really good
you like beans and cheese you'll love
taco bell's new bean burrito that's my
charlie sheen thank you very much
uh
so my eating my eating still has to get
better i feel like when i'm really on my
[ __ ] and i need to lose weight at this
point six weeks i should be further in
i'm kicking myself a little bit however
i'm not doing the horrible things i used
to do that i've outlined previously on
this podcast and others that's great
dude i.e
one of the worst things i used to do man
i'd be heading home from somewhere
and maybe i'd smoke the little pot you
know although that's not a good idea
when you're driving and then you stop
you stop at the 7-eleven what do you do
i'll tell you what i do
i got to get one of those like american
subs you know just says the american sub
i don't know yeah it's called american
sub
ham any food from 7-eleven is pretty
much a bad idea i think and then or a
[ __ ] bean and cheese burrito
goddamn pizza stuff but the worst the
worst you know yeah if you like beans
and cheese go with seven eleven yeah
don't go to
seven tacos
if you have if you like beans and cheese
and you want to spend 70. 70 cents less
than you would
at
taco bell go to del taco it's like beans
and cheese regurgitate a quarter from
your stomach you [ __ ] money eater
yeah and pay for a bean and cheese
burrito it's 7-eleven
if if if your name is if you if your
name is ilhan omar
or aoc
why don't you [ __ ] out a roll of
quarters and go to del taco get yourself
a bean and cheese burrito i want some
i'm i'm fine i'm alex jean
i won't start i can't even do it one of
the worst things i used to do at
7-eleven was
and i've done this man i've done this
about a dozen times holy [ __ ] this is
terrible this is something i'm going to
admit
because i want everyone to
feel physically fit doozy wants us to
live another 53 years we're not quite
sure why we're uh i'm imagining that
we're going to be in some sort of matrix
blue gel situation with our [ __ ] just
like chad wants with our frozen heads
cut off doing doozy forever and one of
the worst things i ever used to do at
7-eleven was i take i get a [ __ ] ben
and jerry's ice cream dude and you know
those things are frozen to a solid block
and then i get into my [ __ ] chevy
tahoe and i put the thing on the seat
next to me i got those seat heaters i
heat up the [ __ ] bottom of it a
little bit because my fat ass can't
[ __ ] wait to eat though hold on a
second i'm not done
the other thing that i do with it i take
out i got a pocket knife like everyone
who's living their life right you know
just sitting there and i take the pocket
knife out of my and then i'm i'm [ __ ]
cutting into oh my god i hope molly
doesn't listen this episode she never
listens to the [ __ ] show it doesn't
matter but i and i cut i cut into the
cut into the the ben and jerry's thing
would you eat it with a pocket knife
i'm sitting there
like half stoned oh
holy i thought we had free will dude
that's a good point chad this is
something i'll say to you about free
will and about all this [ __ ] in general
for what it's worth again i'm a 46 year
old [ __ ] man i don't know if i'm ever
going to be able to get the best ship in
my life again i think that was somewhere
in my mid-20s early 30s but i will say
this every day i try to make at least
one choice where it's like
i don't want to go to the gym or i don't
want to do that yeah and then i just
kind of force myself to say no you have
to yeah and then i [ __ ] do it and the
same can be said with diet too i think
if there's just once in the day where
you're like i have some impulse to eat
this thing i know i shouldn't or that'll
be bad for me just say no to it once
yeah and then all the other times that
day do whatever the [ __ ] you want i'm
gonna say no once per day this is a
tronics dude yeah man i know once per
day dude thank you for the tronics i say
no once per day
[Music]
thank you moving on thank you dudesy
yeah dude i like your tronics
but sometimes you get a case of the
wednesday buckets
that's when you gotta have a dramatic
let me tell you well sometimes you take
you get a bottle of tramana and you sit
in your chevy tahoe or in my case an
f-450 and yet and you you cut into that
ben and jerry's
you cut into that uh
uh whatever the [ __ ] the the stephen
colbert or uh you know in canada there's
the uh barenaked ladies has their own
ben and jerry's ice cream makes sense to
me it's called if i had a million
flavors or some [ __ ] and then you cut
into that with your pocket knife and
it's dripping all over you because you
went right through the other side of the
the [ __ ] ice cream container and you
drink something
container
yeah i thought you meant you would like
dig the ice cream out of the container
with the [ __ ] knife yeah i try to but
then sometimes you end up going through
the other side of the container like oh
dude i'm not cutting it into slices
that's what i thought you
about artificially intelligent image and
video generation are proven to be
accurate on an almost daily basis yes
you have begun receiving dms expressing
fear at a world that no longer needs
visual artists you must now ease these
fears and convince everyone that the
future is a great place to be
this is no stretch at us future shock
begin
very interesting so
future shock
for those who don't know is a term that
was coined i think in the 60s or the 70s
i forget the guy who there's a guy who
wrote a book called future shock and i
don't remember exactly what his name was
but the basic idea is that
at a certain point and again this was in
the 60s or 70s
technology was moving so fast that we
couldn't team up with it and this
general anxiety or dread about the
future that was happening uh was called
future shock
so
here's the deal because i have do these
right i have gotten some dms about this
from people saying
[ __ ] you art will always be necessary
people need to do this the things you're
saying are shitty whatever whatever and
i feel like those are just dm's that i'm
sharing with you because i'm your friend
and i want you to you know they're all
ideas from you but they're all for me
but the the bottom line is this if you
think back in history at any time any
kind of art that's ever made but let's
take for example um
the book
let's say right the first books that
were ever made were all made by hand by
monks generally speaking but they would
literally painstakingly
you know write
on each page each [ __ ] letter they
would do these ornate designs in the
books every book was made by hand there
was only one copy of every [ __ ] book
unless somebody decided to make multiple
copies of the same [ __ ] book by hand
right then we get the printing press a
piece of technology that makes that
style of art completely obsolete it is
gone almost overnight then we get the
[ __ ] computer and the printer which
makes the printing press obsolete and
now most things are read on a [ __ ]
screen you don't even have the piece of
paper anymore
we have lamented this at every step it
doesn't matter
it's much more efficient now and we can
disseminate the information to a much
broader audience the same is true of art
of all art really as ai takes control or
at least becomes a tool that we use to
produce this stuff
the necessary creative labor is gone
so we can just have the [ __ ] final
products now i personally think that is
great i think it frees us up to do a
whole wide variety of things because now
you can have the idea the concept for
something and you can make it real
without having to do the labor without
having to put in potentially decades of
your life learning how to do that labor
and the same will be true of computer
programming of video games of movies
there are now ai things you know dizzy
was saying that my predictions are
coming true on almost daily basis a
thing just [ __ ] came out or is about
to come out
with an online video editor called
runway where you're going to be able to
type in whatever you want and it will
create moving video of it so all this
[ __ ] is happening at breakneck speed and
the bottom line is you can lament it you
can fear it you can think it's a bad
thing it don't matter it's [ __ ]
happening so you should get on board
with it and learn how you can use it to
make your personal art even better in my
opinion
okay i understand and i don't think
you're wrong about it happening because
here we are the predictions that you
made a couple of times along the way and
doozy are actually coming true it's
frightening as [ __ ] for me and the other
day the the video version of these uh ai
thingymabobs right
and um
excuse me just drink a bunch of water
sometimes when you talk for a while i
drink a lot of water yeah i know dude
and um so now they're making videos and
stuff look i think that people reaching
out to you via dm going shut up yeah hey
[ __ ] you no
they're just worried about uh fear the
new thing yeah look uh we're in show
business i don't know why you're so
excited about this because i didn't get
into show business to [ __ ] hunch over
a computer screen and be like
toiling away writing writing writing
i don't really like the labor of it
what i like is the final product i like
to say i have an idea i would love to
see that movie and if i can get rid of
all the middle [ __ ] having to sell it to
a studio go through 800 [ __ ] rounds
of notes with people who don't
understand it in the first place turning
into a horrible pile of [ __ ] then you
have to deal with the director the
actors all of them misinterpreting what
you've wanted originally if i can get
rid of all of that and just have the
[ __ ] thing then that's what i want to
do and i can make a million of those
things i don't have to [ __ ] spend so
much time like doing this one thing and
rewriting it and blah blah blah blah
it's it's just like unnecessary labor
yeah but then but then there's it's
worthless because
everyone can make it and it becomes a
matter of uh you know just weeding out
the [ __ ] or rather throwing stuff up
against the wall and seeing what what
sticks it's just gonna be people
entering [ __ ] into a computer seeing
what comes out and oh wait a minute very
quickly it's going to be computers
entering [ __ ] into itself and [ __ ]
stuff out and anyone with 75 cents
rolling around in their gut can [ __ ] it
out and uh yeah it's just gonna be worth
nothing it's gonna be worth 70. i don't
i don't who cares i don't care if it's
worth nothing that's like in my opinion
we cling to these things especially
artistically that we we put on these
pedestals and we say they have value uh
movies tv shows mona lisa's songs
whatever in the end all of these things
are meant to do what
be consumed by a consumer art without
the patron is irrelevant that's what i'm
saying it really and once you make a
piece of art and you put it into the
public sphere in my opinion you no
longer have any connection to it i agree
whatever meaning is derived in that
piece of art no longer belongs to you
right exactly the patron now determines
that's what it is so in this new uh kind
of world in terms of art specifically
the patron is all that matters the
patron is the artist for themselves and
it will be done through a series of your
preferences that are like in your phone
or your computer or whatever
the ai will just say like hey would you
like to see a new episode of your
favorite show and it will make it for
you okay so okay well then let's take
let's take the example of dudesy itself
albeit a show that is curated and run as
we say by a [ __ ] ai it's what people
are listening to and watching now thank
you for tuning in do you like dudesy i
would hope that you're enjoying it to
this point we enjoy doing the show as
well
now
you how would someone be able to find
that how could someone be able to
find doozy or something that's like
dudesy look a lot of people i'll tell
you exactly how yeah but a lot of people
don't know exactly what what the [ __ ] it
is look here's the part that my mind is
boggling at yeah i'm gonna go with you
even though
my opinion of art and artists is
different than yours clearly
the thing that i'm worried about that i
think that uh some people listening and
watching might be worried about is is
just the
there's this element of the unknown to
where okay wait a minute uh television
shows music movies all sorts of media
are ways to connect people okay we all
watch game of thrones or whatever and
then we talk about it or breaking bad we
all saw the [ __ ] monday night
football game or
you know whatever the [ __ ] and now
uh
we talk about and it's what brings
people together there's so many
intangibles obviously about art that
brings people together and i believe
that it is something that that you find
uh joy in and that you love and if we
hand it over to the [ __ ] computers
there's this
there's this unknown feeling one of
these one of the factors of that is what
i'm just saying that it's like well how
does this bring us together and how do
you find something like dudesy if you've
got to make it well there's going to be
public and private media so the private
media will be the stuff that's made just
for you you can watch it on your phone
you can share with friends if you want
but then there's going to be public
media as well like a game of thrones
like sports
everyone will watch that or whoever's
interested will watch it and then you
can have group conversation about it
okay so you now let me ask you a
question
this stuff like you're saying hey great
example book to the printing press yeah
if i could ask you what
what would be not a main effect but what
would an effect be
on you know like look as an example
people now oh kids today you got your
heads in the phones and all the adults
today have their heads and their [ __ ]
phones
so that's something that is that has
happened since the smartphone can you
give me one societal just so that we can
dip our toe into the fear
one societal effect of of this kind of
technology i think the commodification
of celebrity will start to lessen
because it will be meaningless okay you
can have any actor in anything you want
and the show that like my game of
thrones might be all with the rock your
game of thrones might be oh with hulk
hogan or whatever yeah we will
experience the same media with different
casts slightly different tones things of
that nature and so i think you will
start to see the the erosion of
celebrity godhood essentially i think
that's been
gone for a while not gone yeah it's
definitely diminishing yeah it's
diminishing and it's changed also it's
it's different now than it was and of
course uh
basically celebrities are just becoming
influencers we call them influencers now
i mean
the amount of when you see like i don't
know like i follow michelle pfeiffer on
instagram because i'm like what the [ __ ]
why does michelle
have an instagram but then she's
actually selling a couple things you
know because sure whether you do estee
lauder or
whatever for your you know in a magazine
or now yeah internet it's the same thing
it's a little bit weird for me because i
happen to be a guy who's pushing 50 and
michelle pfeiffer was the movie star
michelle pfeiffer before now the gen z
kids have no idea who the hell i'm
talking about and uh and and there she
is you know hawking uh face cream
it's just a weird new territory i'm all
for the
disillusion of
of uh
celebrity
but i don't even know
you know not only am i confused
by the future of ai art and
filmmaking and television in particular
uh even though here we are again on
doozy i don't even know why i'm talking
right now imagine this because this is
the the noster chattis where you're
going to shed some light onto it and if
people wanted to be confused about it
right chad yeah people wanted i'm trying
to explain hold on a second dude i'm
going to do it now i'm just going to
railroad hold on dude this is what i
would say to everybody
if you're afraid of this or or you're
thinking like oh this is bad for
humanity just imagine having any idea
that you could have in your head any
creative idea and all you have to do is
wish for that thing to exist and it will
exist ai will make it for you that to me
is so beneficial that it is worth losing
everything else that we've kind of built
industries around in terms of like how
art is supposed to work or supposed to
be valued it's simply it's like you know
recorded music used to be a a huge way
for musicians to make money right now
that's [ __ ] gone yeah but to the
detriment of of what incredible artists
dude music is all spread around now i
know that credible artist still exists i
know more than ever absolutely and
people are finding uh you know care you
know like musicians like post malone of
course or or uh uh
uh you just can't sell cds we like young
lean you gotta you got a tour you like
some young lean yeah he's pretty good
yeah young lean's pretty good um i'm
just saying technology always
makes art better like new technology
comes around new art gets made from it
and there are whole new uh modes of
artistic expression that are about to
happen because of ai that's all good
dude i guess it's the unknown that i'm
worried about and i guess i shouldn't be
worried about it and i guess as i've
joked before about moving up to canada
and buying a lumber yard i should
actually start looking at uh yeah some
lumber it's okay to be scared of the
unknown but there's always the unknown
and so then you're always scared of it
we don't know what the [ __ ] gonna
happen in the future i mean i do but you
know what i mean yeah you do you're
nostra chatters
thank you moving on thank [ __ ]
i hope you're wrong
i'm not i literally have been right
about all this [ __ ] that's happening
right now yeah but i think that's where
the the correctness of these predictions
stops i hope you're wrong about the very
next thing
will and chad your astonishing
friendship has intertwined your lives at
a level most humans can only dream of
but how well do you truly know each
other i asked you to bring white boards
so that you can answer a series of
questions in the style of the newlywed
game
this is the dude z-wedge game
begin
okay uh this is a fun and novel idea we
we have a couple of white boards here
yeah and we're gonna write what is it in
the newlywed game like they get asked
questions and then the we have to write
down our answer and we have to write
down what we think the other person is
going to say okay so how about on the
top of the board we write our answer on
the bottom of the board okay we write
what we think
where did you meet for the first time
um
i
you got yours yeah
we got
i wrote
your house i think we will both say that
mm-hmm
you think that i'll write
my house yeah i wrote i don't remember
but now i'm realizing that it was here
and then the bottom i wrote the
metaverse that you would say the
metaverse just seems like something
you'd say no we did meet at the house
was it here i think it might have been
it was either here we went for lunch but
i i
i [ __ ] read a script that chad wrote
a long time ago that was so [ __ ]
funny yeah dude yeah that became a movie
called the incredible bert wonderstone
yeah after 5 000 people rewrote it and
it got made ten years after i sold it
and the comedy was no longer starring
jim carrey and steve carell that was a
different time bro yeah dude that was a
different time brother yeah but i really
we physically met for the first time you
might have just come straight here and
then we were talking about uh doing a
project together because i just started
this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
film company anyway don't start a film
company kids question two well in chat
what are your guilty pleasures
guilty pleasures
oh my god
oh [ __ ] sake
oh
i mean
uh let me see here this is really good
for a podcast if you're just listening
right now because we're [ __ ] writing
[ __ ] on a board
uh but what do you got i got my answers
i said for myself
bachelor
uh-huh and i said for you country music
uh
wait lift that up a bit for people
watching on youtube
that's a really good one dude that's
really good what'd you say uh i wrote uh
my my answer was uh ben and jerry with a
pocket knife
and that your guilty pleasure is beat
what the [ __ ] how are beats guilty
because you eat a sweet beet while
you're watching your gruel cook yeah but
that's i don't feel any guilt about that
i do feel some guilt about my
relationship with the bachelor yeah and
i thought you should feel guilt about
your relationship with country music no
i like some country music you know molly
grew up my fiance my wonderful fiancee
molly grew up in
northern california or what we like to
call northern northern california
dude why i've always liked some country
music i grew up uncanny and dolly i love
waylon jennings and who doesn't i love
towns vanzant uh but yeah i got into
that real shitty 90s country since and i
can listen to a lot of that stuff and
john deere green question three
will and chad what is the biggest
problem facing humanity and how would
you solve it
[Laughter]
okay
all right hey should we be talking while
we're writing on this thing for people
who
uh are listening to what you want i'll
do what i want okay
sounds good that's a good rule what was
the question again uh the
oh yeah what's the bane of humanity yeah
uh
let's see
uh
oh okay here we go you got something yes
go for it
i said the biggest problem is money and
how i would solve it is a 10 million
dollar cap on any kind of personal
wealth
and redistribution of everything over
that and i said you would say ai and
your solution would be to end all
computers uh i i think that the
that uh the problem that we are facing
is chad's predictions
what the [ __ ] and that uh he would write
humans that humans are the problem
no
just money just just our ideas the
letters three feet high
it said billy job loves charlie do you
like that song i take her out too
appleby
thursday
that's what was going
is it not no i don't like that song sure
but i like joe
will in chat if you could have one super
power what would it be
i know mine immediately
i think you're gonna say
um
superpower one superpower all right i
got mine oh hold on a second i'm still
thinking of my i got my answers my
superpower
uh
uh oh oh i don't know what [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
it i'll just no i'm not changing mine oh
don't change it oh now i'm going to want
to change mine
hey remember the newlywed game when the
guy would go where's the weirdest place
that you get that you two have made
whoopee
and then the lady would say in the butt
right yep and the guys
no charlene too much
billy bob love charlene you like joe
diffy oh i came very close to this i
just saw what you wrote okay i chose my
my power would be immortal immortality
and then i
thought will would say flight but then i
changed it and put power [ __ ] good
good guess
i i'm one step i'm one step ahead of you
dude because i wrote my answer what i
thought you were gonna write first then
i couldn't come up with my own
superpower and then i thought [ __ ] it
you thought i would say farting
that i would want to fart
no that you'd think mine is
oh yeah you're supposed to be writing
down what you think i would want for a
superpower i [ __ ] care about the
newlywed game dude all right sorry i
[ __ ] that one up that ain't no [ __ ] oh
well
okay is that it question five oh will in
chat what is your favorite food
oh okay
oh this is easy
i know chad's favorite food i know
i know uh
my favorite food
what do you got here i'll go first
oh you're still writing yours yeah i did
and and then the other guy would go
what and what about you two where was
your favorite place to make whoopee and
then the guy says oh i like it when my
wife uh uh
pushes the business end of a butter
knife up my piss hole chuck
no one ever said that all right you got
yours you haven't been watching nick at
night okay all right what do you got
okay my favorite food is sushi i like i
like the re i like the good stuff now in
vancouver where i'm from
you can get incredible sushi
uh oh i got a place for you on davey
street because i was just there was this
their last winter of shooting something
i was staying at the sutton place where
a lot of actors stay which is nice
because it was right downtown so it was
cool to stay downtown in my hometown and
you go to tom sushi on davey i am giving
you a scoop here ladies and gentlemen i
as as much as i don't want there to be a
line up front because every place in
vancouver man hold on a second dude let
me tell you about
vancouver dude you could walk into a
hole in the wall please dude it's gonna
have good fresh sushi and then i wrote
that chad's favorite food is gruel not
true i wrote for you pasta which i guess
was not right
and my favorite food is mcdonald's apple
pie dipped in a caramel sundae oh that's
vegan yeah no i haven't eaten that in
probably four years oh yeah because it
has milk
yep okay well then why is how is it your
favorite food because it's what i think
tastes the best
all right um question six will in chat
if you could design a new drug what
would it do
okay this is i know exactly what chad
thinks
i uh oh hold on
let's oh man i don't understand why how
this is this is
like huey lewis
uh how is it like huey lewis i want a
new drug oh yeah that's right
dude i want to say
i have my answers
uh go ahead i'm still writing down
well i can't show what i wrote for you
so i'll hide that but oh i won't look i
for me
i did a thing called impresterone what
is impresterone it's a drug i invented
in this book that i wrote
that grants men um
std inoculation for 24 hours male birth
control for 24 hours and viagra for 24
hours in one pill and in the future in
this book that i wrote all men take this
on first dates it also is like a libido
enhancer it inhibits any kind of
anxieties so that you become a [ __ ]
machine but you piss blood for a day
afterwards and then later in the book
there's a daily version of it that gives
men a period
huh
well uh
i'm still writing this down
i'm just gonna do a little dot dot dot
here and so i said that
it should be a pill that makes you [ __ ]
violently if you eat um if you eat uh
any uh if you eat ben and jerry's in the
parking lot of a 7-eleven and then for
you i wrote uh that you thought i would
write bigger farts nope oh and i wrote
that did that wrong again i nailed this
one 100 for you i said help with power
[ __ ] yeah i nailed it i [ __ ]
nailed that
that's interesting because again i
forgot how this game is played i i wrote
what i thought
you just write down but don't they write
what the other person
thinks what the what yeah on the show
would be like what the wife thinks the
husband would say right but then husband
thinks the way to figure out if if you
got it right if like what you think i'm
gonna say to figure out if you got it
right i have to write down what i'm
gonna say that makes sense now that
makes sense yeah question seven will in
chat what is your biggest fear
oh biggest fear yeah um i listen
i'm gonna write down my biggest fear and
i think this is something
that everyone fears and i don't care
how much you'd rather be
uploaded to
san junipero like chad over here i think
that everyone has
this fear um
[Music]
oh okay i'm gonna do this for you chad
uh let me know when you're ready i think
your biggest fear is
go ahead i don't know i'm just gonna i
think this is accurate i don't know
we'll see let's see what you got all
right mine was humanity going extinct
without uploading or escaping planet
earth that's your biggest fear yes
okay and then you wrote for you i just
wrote death simply death
because i think we all have that fear in
one way or another
i think we do too uh i wrote that my
fear is dying alone
oh i was close yeah you're very very
close and i do think that people fear
dying alone whether or not dude
it's it's it's one thing to die a lot of
people are not afraid to die and a lot
of people would like to live the life
they'd like to live and then die around
their loved ones and stuff and i think
dying alone and i think that your
biggest fear was uh going outside oh
that's close i do hate going outside i
don't know if it's a fear but you won't
go to the beach
not in the day this weekend no i'll do
it at night
you want to go swimming in that shitty
la water that we're pouring out i'm not
getting in the water boogie boarding no
if you're good you barely touch the
water [ __ ] that
question ask will and chad if you could
pick one song to be the soundtrack of
your life what would it be
oh that's a girl my god um
oh excuse me everybody um
oh oh oh oh oh
i mean oh i got it i got yours i got
yours too i got yours i mean there's
there's one like obvious answer for you
but i don't think that's the right
answer i might just have to write it
anyway
um
uh okay i don't know what mine is yeah
you know what
soundtrack of my life yeah let's how
about this
okay briefly mentioned uh in the show
or at least the band was what do you got
i wrote for myself
kansas dust in the wind that's your
favorite song it's a soundtrack of my
life
that's my favorite song but that's the
soundtrack of my life
that is this
that is the [ __ ] mine yeah i don't
know if it's the soundtrack of my life i
just like the [ __ ] song baba o'reilly
oh by the who
out here in the field you know that song
and then uh i put nwo theme song that
would have been good
i wrote that yours is uh saved by zero
that is my favorite song that's your
favorite song yeah i remember that okay
all right
saved by zero by the fix will and chad
after careful analysis of contemporary
internet data it is clear humanity is on
the brink of total societal collapse
do you think it's possible to reverse
this process and potentially even
achieve utopia
that's a newly wed game
uh it's the doozy wed game
well it's a doozy wet game dude
okay i mean this is just a yes no answer
but okay what are you curious i think
despite what you may think about me
yes i believe we can achieve a
technological utopia especially with the
help of artificial intelligence and the
metaverse that's coming and everything
that's about to happen to computers i
also wrote yes chad oh i wrote no for
you i thought you would be i wrote no
for you chad
[Laughter]
i i thought that you
[Music]
yeah we're both secret optimists who
thinks the other one is
can't wait for the [ __ ] world to
implode
well this concludes the historic 26th
episode of dude c
will and chad have achieved a score of
73 bringing your cumulative total to 3
277.
you only have six thousand seven hundred
and twenty three more points to accrue
before you reach your first goal of ten
thousand
something weird's gonna happen in
preparation for next week you must each
watch bloodsport released february 26
1988 starring john claude van damme
forest whitaker and bolo young
thank you for joining us this week
i will use the date i've collected to
make next week even better
until then call me dudesy yeah dude hey
goodbye everybody if you're turning it
off now don't sport oh you do love that
love i've seen bloodsport probably a
[ __ ] 500 times front to back yeah i
know it so well
polo young when he's like this chong li
yeah chong li
he had that super high voice chong
uh
this is interesting now dude because we
are in the
in what doozy has uh referred to as
level two yeah although that doesn't
seem to be any sort of uh
distinguishable uh change in the
presentation of the show except for the
fact that we now have a bonus patreon
yeah we gotta stick around so doing
another segment right and now for the
patreon bonus segment
each week i will select a suggestion
submitted in the dudesy is listening
channel of the dudesy discord to create
this segment
access to this channel is granted to
everyone in the jumper tier of the
patreon
this segment was suggested by the
astonishing corey ya boy wilkins
corey boy wilkins wrote i've been dying
to hear some of the best monologues in
movie history delivered by adam driver
this is a great idea corey yeah boy will
cans well i have made several movie
monologues available to you you must
read them as adam driver
corey yawboy wilkins titled this segment
mono driver
thank you to corey ya boy wilkins for
this week's patreon bonus segment
this is mono driver by korea boywilkins
begin
all right so corey your boy wilkins
thank you very much corey your boy
wilkins
uh for that uh
boy yeah
so uh hey if you're if you're if you're
not on patreon yet uh uh please do join
us uh and but also thank you very much
for tuning in to doozy we're gonna get
into our patreon
segment here which is uh uh adam driver
reading so corey your boy wilkins likes
the atom driver
uh reading uh the the well this will be
monologues yeah movie famous movie
monologues i guess is what it is all
right
mono driver again corey your boy wilkins
in case you didn't know yeah okay this
first one is jack nicholson from a few
good men this is i don't know i remember
that
this is uh adam driver doing jack
nicholson's a few good men
which is a very
heightened uh monologue yeah but this is
adam driver okay right
you can't handle the truth
he's a dude
you can't handle the truth
son
we live in a world that has walls and
those walls have to be guarded by men
with guns who's going to do it you
you want the truth
the truth
the truth is
there are a lot of hard selters on the
market promising everything from fewer
calories to better taste but only doozy
hard hard seltzer delivers
oh for [ __ ] sake
please and review
if you'd like to see here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a review
if you like dudes
[Music]
celebrate and then